Europe toujours sous la forme d'erlione
et Charles Michel ont réitéré sans
surprise de soutien de l'Union
européenne à Kiev lieu que l'Ukraine
veut rejoindre nous sommes avec vous
aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra voilà
pour les mots de la présidente de la
Commission européenne bonjour Caroline
de Camaret vous êtes bien sur la
spécialiste de l'Europe ici à France 24
nouveau train également il faut dire un
Européen de sanction contre la Russie
l'UE qui soutient Kef et qui lui ouvre
la porte pour une adhésion ce n'est pas
négligeable oui alors on a souvent mis
en avant peut-être un impossible retard
de l'Union européenne mais si on regarde
de plus près ce qu'il en a été c'est
vrai que l'Europe de l'Est toute cette
Europe de l'Est a à plus mis en garde
contre Vladimir Poutine que celle que
celle de l'Ouest et
mets les sanctions néanmoins étaient
déclenchés assez vite en fait dès le 21
février reconnaissance de l'indépendance
de territoire séparatiste de denies par
la Russie premier homme de sanctions
tout de même qui était préparé ce sont
des sanctions qui ont été un peu
millimétrées par le spin doctor de
Ursula vanderlion à la Commission
européenne l'école américaine un peu qui
disait on va essayer de trouver des
sanctions qui à la fois ne heurtent pas
directement très très vite notre
économie mais très fortement le plus
fortement possible celle de la Russie et
soit acceptable à chaque à chaque moment
par effectivement les Européens donc
c'est ce train de sanction il a été
adopté très systématiquement après le 24
février première grande salle de
sanction le 25 février avec
effectivement les secteurs financiers de
l'énergie des transports il y a eu
effectivement aussi le 16 mars exclusion
de la Russie du Conseil de l'Europe qui
est une autre institution mais qui était
quand même et un geste très fort aussi
et puis il y a eu à la suite de la
découverte en avril du massacre de
boucha l'idée qu'il fallait aller
au-delà et avec le 23 juin vous l'avez
dit cette candidature de l'Ukraine et
par et du voisin voldave aussi par la
même occasion ouverte donc candidature
reconnue à l'Union européenne et ça
c'était quelque chose de fort bien sûr
et puis il y a eu des explosions en
Pologne on s'est demandé s'il y avait
s'il y avait anguille sous roche il y a
eu le lancement d'une mission européenne
militaire de formation de 30 000
militaires aujourd'hui sur le sol
européen 30000 militaires ukrainiens et
l'Allemagne qui décide de livrer dernier
épisode en date le 25 janvier des
charlourds à l'Ukraine alors si on
regarde l'ensemble de cette aide
européenne on se rend compte que on est
autour de 50 milliards d'euros dont 10
milliards pour l'aide seulement
militaires c'est bien sur beaucoup moins
que les États-Unis car moins mais du
côté de l'aide économique en tant que
tel c'est très puissant 18 milliards
d'euros en effet on essaye aujourd'hui
de boucler le dixième round de sanctions
mais ça n'est pas encore fait alors
Vladimir Poutine on le sait avait prédit
la mort de l'Union européenne la mort de
l'OTAN un an plus tard ces deux
institutions ne se sont pas effondrées
bien au contraire oui puis surtout vous
l'avez
l'Union européenne elle a fait envie aux
Ukrainiens c'est ce qu'il faut retenir
quand même envie au point que finalement
il demande une candidature express et il
l'obtiennent d'un certain point de vue
ils ont c'est du jamais vu de l'obtenir
aussi vite ils veulent maintenant
l'ouverture des négociations d'adhésion
à la fin de cette année ça veut dire un
rapport positif ils font des efforts de
lutte contre la corruption le président
zélincks qui a fait un peu le ménage
notamment au ministère de la Défense qui
avait un certain nombre d'affaires et
donc ils essayent de prendre ce chemin
l'OTAN l'OTAN a été évidemment renforcé
par la candidature et de la Suède et de
la Finlande qui bloque toujours pour un
certain nombre de pays notamment hors de
l'Union Européenne mais pays candidats à
la Turquie et plus important de façon
plus importante là Hongrie de Victor
urban est en train de faire un petit
chantage aussi par rapport à l'entrée de
ces deux pays dans l'OTAN mais on voit
bien que cet auto est renforcé peut-être
c'est au détriment aussi de
l'indépendance stratégique de la défense
européenne tellement voulu par un
Emmanuel Macron
et qui qui commençait à se construire
entre la France et l'Allemagne par celle
de l'autre qui aujourd'hui et bien en
tout cas paraît moins efficace dans
l'immédiateté de cette guerre que que le
le bouclier de l'OTAN que que les pays
de l'Est ont toujours en quelque sorte
révérée revenons quand même juste sur un
pays un pays qui bloque ce dixième rang
de sanction aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
celui qu'on attendait là Hongrie bloque
régulièrement et le bloqueur en chef
aujourd'hui au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est
là c'est Varsovie qui bloque un dixième
rang de sanctions parce qu'on il
considère qu'on ne va pas assez loin
dans les sanctions sur le caoutchouc les
exportations plus de caoutchouc
notamment parce que l'Italie a besoin de
pneus pour ses voitures et que donc on
serait dans mi-figue mi raisin donc ce
dixième rang il n'est pas encore
finalisé aujourd'hui ça s'est un peu
dommage parce que dedans il y avait des
choses assez novatrices et notamment des
sanctions contre les propagandistes
russes et ça c'était une première aussi
donc on attend aussi aujourd'hui une
bonne nouvelle du côté
du 10e rang de sanction Varsovie qui a
donc